foreign
[Music]
I'm Nate Avery I'm an outbound product
manager at Google and today we'll
we'll go over some practices for devops
velocity and security on Google Cloud
I want to set the stage up front we're
going to do some welcome and intros
we'll talk devops culture Dora use of
cloud and then we'll have our guests
tell us about their proven results and a
perspective from the ground if this is
not what you thought this session would
be I totally understand and you're free
to
another session
um
okay so this is us
we know that most teams are going to
want to improve velocity right that's
the rate at which changes are made and
put into production
and this group of practitioners here
we all come from a variety of places
there are some of us at Google
in product management we have software
engineers and then we have folks from
industry who've got great experience
doing this and explaining it and working
with it on a day-to-day basis the goal
of all of this is to share with you real
life practices that should work we don't
want you to believe it just because we
say it but because it can work elsewhere
Okay so
so we'll get to get things started by
talking about Dora
that's where most of the tips are going
to come from
devops research and assessment
is what door stands for and it will
start in 2015.
Google Cloud purchased it in 2018. now
even though we bought it
um we continue to to invest in it and
expand it the goal is to increase
capacity to help our customers
understand
just how they can apply the research
that's being done we want to make it
real and actionable
in terms of the number of folks who work
on this there are 33 000 professionals
worldwide who've contributed data to
this and we have lots of bright people
and lots of bright math and all kinds of
stuff going into this to help peel back
the onion and help us understand what's
actually happening and what are the
trends and what are some of the things
that you can do to improve your in your
environment
Okay so
unless you're like brand new to it
you've probably seen this before
devops isn't just about tech it's about
tech and culture
and it feels a bit of a cliche to say it
but we kind of have to because we
actually have stats to prove it
we look to the research to help us
understand the devops world and provide
us with some insights
our most recent report
it said that there was a clear drop in
the high in the elite groups and what's
interesting about that is that it
suggests that this year's respondents
were either just starting their devops
culture or had a very poor devops
culture so again we're starting to see
that you can't just ignore it
and here's another chart here
no surprise to anyone that the Dream
Team there they're performance oriented
they have above average team stability
above average support above average
flexibility
I mean that's kind of what it takes
um
so we'll take a look at some of the
metrics
the report breaks down aspects of
software delivery into two types speed
and stability
now everybody wants to make things
faster I mean that's kind of a universal
deal
but organizations will often say that
they can have either speed or stability
right it thinks like a trade-off
and I think we've all been in places
where someone said
you can have it fast or you can have it
right you know which one do you want
but what's interesting is that our data
tells us that you don't have to
sacrifice these at all that they're both
actually
complementary in their outcomes of a
good environment
so
there's a lot in it to buy in if you buy
into it properly you will benefit
foreign
there are four main metrics in Dora to
be aware of
lead time for change that's you know how
long how long does it take for commit to
get into production
deployment frequency which is how often
you release software
change failure rate
what percentage of releases degrade
production
and then meantime to re to restore
service
which is how quickly can you recover if
there is a problem
and I gotta mention something here
do not try to game these metrics
it's very tempting
a lot of us want to a lot of people are
into like you know trying to hit targets
but that's not really what we're doing
here
the goal of this is to measure where
your environment is
you make a change
you measure it again and you compare
hopefully you're better off than you
were but you might not be things happen
so what do you do you just do it again
you make make a change measure it
compare it
see if you're better off
the idea here is that we're going to
treat our people and our teams and our
procedures the same way we we would
treat software which isn't an iterative
approach
and again some
the numbers
are here to just kind of solidify this
right we want you to walk away knowing
that there actually was some effort and
that
there's a reason why you should stick
into this
114 times more frequent code deployments
three times lower change failure rates
uh what is that 23.7 times faster time
to do to deploy I mean that's kind of
nice oh sorry deploy was 26.5
even better
so
there's one other aspect here I got to
talk about and that's use of the cloud
yeah I know I'm a cloud guy we're at a
cloud conference
um I probably being paid somewhat to
talk about cloud
um
but again when we talk about cloud in
relation to Dora it actually works out
pretty good because
we see that for that those who are on
cloud are 14 more likely to succeed in
their organization performance goals
so again we're looking at the things
that work and that really kind of push
the envelope for customers
so
these guys here they're just a small
sample of some of the partners we work
with definitely not an exhaustive list
and now I'm going to hand things over to
Christy for a demo thank you
first try hi everybody I'm Christy
Warwick I'm a software engineer at
Google where I co-created an open source
CI CD framework called tecton
I am so passionate about continuous
delivery that I actually wrote a book
about it it took three years I don't
recommend it but that's not what I'm
here to talk to you about today today I
want to show you how you can use gcp to
take what Nate was saying and actually
put it into practice
so
the project that I'm going to use is one
that's in this GitHub repo here and it's
a really simple project that just shows
population statistics for countries
because the truth is that ideally we
would bake all this stuff in from the
start but the reality is that it's rare
that we get to work on Greenfield
projects we're usually working on
something that already exists so that's
what we're going to do today we're going
to take this project that already exists
and we're going to improve the stability
the speed and the security
so let's take a look at this project so
the way that this project works is that
it's built into a Docker image that's
deployed to gke and we manage those
deployments using Cloud deploy which
sounds pretty good from the start but
there are some problems
so the team that's working on this finds
that they get outages almost every time
that they deploy as a result this has
made them really nervous to do
deployments so if we look from a Dora
perspective it's not looking great the
deployment frequency is low because
people are afraid to make changes
because the deployment frequency is low
the lead time for changes is high and
then the change failure rate is also
really high the one thing we have going
for us is that cloud deploy makes
rollbacks pretty easy so at least the
time to restore is pretty fast so let's
figure out how we can improve this
we'll take a quick look at a bug that
managed to make it into production so
this is a bug that made it to production
and caused an outage with the entire
service
one of the things that went wrong here
is that the change went out to all the
users at once and took everybody down so
one way that we can improve that since
we're already using Cloud deploy is that
we can use a canary deployment
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take my cloud deploy configuration and
I'm going to add a canary deployment
strategy so what this will do is when I
make a change instead of going out to
all the users a canary deployment will
be created and it'll only hit about five
percent of users and then a verification
will happen so that way we'll find out
if anything's wrong
at the same time I'm going to use
another feature
of cloud deploy and I'm going to add
some regionalization so previously I
already created several more kubernetes
clusters we have the US cluster that I
was already showing you and then we have
one in Europe and one in Asia as well so
I'm going to use a multi-target rollout
so that using Cloud deploy I can deploy
in parallel to all of those targets at
once and all of that will be behind this
Canary deployment so let's see what that
looks like
so I'm going to apply my configuration
this is the world's saddest gcp cluster
because I've been doing this to it
repeatedly for several days so hopefully
it doesn't mind so let's take a look so
now our production Target actually has
three child targets behind it which are
the US Europe and Asia targets and it's
using a canary deployment so let's see
what would happen if I put that same
broken change out into production now
that I'm using a canary deployment
so I previously built an image that
contains that bug and I'm going to
create a new Cloud deploy release
using that image
so here we go
let's go over and look at Cloud deploy
look at our Pipeline and we should see
here's our new release
it's cued and you can see that the
canary rollouts are about to start so
while we wait for that I'm going to add
a little bit more stability so it would
be great if changes didn't even make it
out to production at all if they had
problems so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to add a staging environment
before the production and production
environment
so over here in my cloud deploy
configuration I have another kubernetes
cluster that I made that's going to be
our staging cluster and I'm going to
update the delivery pipeline so that
before anything makes it out to
production it's going to go to staging
and the last thing I'm going to add is
I'm going to add a manual approval step
between staging and production
so let's see what that looks like
all right
so over in Cloud deploy oh our Canary
rollout started
and you'll see that now we have a
staging environment and there's a manual
approval step between staging and
production so we'll let that Canary keep
going hopefully it'll finish in time for
me to show you but what will happen is
that the canaries will fail and then we
can roll back from that to a previous
good release
all right so what have we accomplished
so we've added more stability to
our pipeline to our application by
adding Canary deployment to production
so if something does make it all the way
there that has a problem at least it'll
only get out to a small number of users
so that should make our change failure
rate lower and our change failure rate
should be even lower because we can
actually try things out in staging now
before they get there and if things do
make it all the way past the canary
maybe all the way to the canary we can
roll them back really easily because we
just have to roll back the canaries not
the whole thing so our time to restore
should be even higher
okay so now we've improved the stability
now we can work on the speed and it's
important to note that we don't want to
work on speed first because if things
are unstable and we just start moving
faster then you'll just be pushing
broken stuff out to production faster
which would actually make everything
worse so we got a bit more stability
let's start moving a little bit faster
so it's great that we're going to get a
signal from our canaries before problems
hit all of our production users but
wouldn't it be nice if changes didn't
even make it here at all and we could
actually find us get the signal that
something's broken even earlier so it
turns out that in our project we
actually have some unit tests already
and it turns out that the unit tests
would have actually caught that bug that
I was showing you earlier but we're
depending on developers to run those
unit tests manually so instead what we'd
really like is we like to stop changes
from being merged at all if the unit
tests don't pass so what we're going to
do is we're going to use cloud build to
run tests on pull requests so that we
can catch these failures before they
actually get merged
so here's my cloud build yaml that I
created that'll run those tests and I'm
going to go into Cloud build I'm going
to add a trigger
to run that on each pull request
so I'll run it on a pull request
I'm going to use the repository that I
already linked
and I'm going to check this handy box
that will make the results show up as a
check in GitHub
so now let's take a look at what would
happen if I tried to open a pull request
that has that bug in it
so we'll create a new pull request
I'll use a branch that already has that
bug
creating the pull request
and so now
Cloud build should kick in and start
running the tests I noticed this was a
little bit slow earlier and one thing
that's a little odd is you can see that
I could just merge this right now if you
wanted that to not happen you can just
add Branch protection
to your GitHub repo and you could make
it so that checks like that one from
cloud build are required before anything
could get merged so hopefully this is
going to
kick in and run the tests if it doesn't
then I can show you the results from a
previous run
okay let's take a look at results from a
so back over here
we can see this one
this was actually you know what I'll
show you it in GitHub because it'll be
even more exciting
so let's look at one of the ones that
failed previously
I think this one
all right so
over here you can see that there are
checks that ran this was my cloud build
check it shows a summary here you can
see the logs from the cloud build run
and you get a link to Cloud build so you
can go and dig in
and see more
really
not gonna run okay let me just
let me just look at the trigger really
quickly and see if any pull request
enabled okay it's a mystery all right so
meanwhile let's let's pretend that those
tests actually ran and they failed
which would catch my error at this point
I can have actually I feel bad not
showing you at least anything no okay
okay so pretending that those tests
failed we can have more confidence now
that the code that's in our repository
is in good shape because if something
gets merged and makes it in then we know
that at least the tests pass
so with that increased confidence we can
actually go a step further and how about
we start automatically rolling things
out to our staging environment
cool and over here you can see that the
canary the canary deployment did fail
and so we can cancel that we're going to
initiate a rollout roll back to a
previous release which will give our
tests even more of a chance to actually
run which would be nice
okay so we're rolling back that bad
Canary that we tried to deploy earlier
no nothing
nothing
oh well okay so the other thing that we
can do
is we can we're going to add a cloud
build trigger that will automatically
deploy to our staging environment so I
have a cloud build configuration file
here that I made that builds a Docker
image pushes it it uses artifact
registry to generate an s-bomb which
I'll be coming back to in a little bit
and then it uses Cloud deploy to create
a release and then waits for the release
to be successful
so I'll add another trigger here
and this this trigger is going to happen
on push to a branch
let me use this so every time that we
push to the main branch which is
essentially what happens when a merge
occurs oh you know what I know what I
did sorry I know how to fix this I know
how to fix this hold on a second I know
what I did
I'm just going to try one more time okay
let's try this I I uh I didn't change
the name of the cloud build yaml
so on a pull request this is the one
that's going to work I'm really I'm
really excited
uh okay
it's not called Cloud build yaml it's
called Cloud build test
all right and send the logs to GitHub
now I probably have to close this
because
and we don't want to close it
and close it and reopen it
it's going to be worth it it's going to
be so fantastic you'll see the test that
you already know is going to fail fail
create pull request
request
Magic
run the tests come on you can do it run
the test run the test okay well anyways
okay so let's create the trigger that
we'll do our deployment to staging
all right so push do branch
and it's a cloud build deploy
all right
nope
Repository
second generation repository that one
okay so it would be really nice if that
one ran too but oh well so I'm not going
to merge that because it is broken but
let's say that we caught the bug and I
go back over here and I want to fix my
bug
so I'm going to go over here and I'm
going to fix the bug because we just had
a little inversion in the logic that we
meant to have there
uh
get push over here
all right
so over here my change is pushed the
test should run again no tests are
running
oh well merge
merge with no confidence but let's
pretend that that worked okay so now
that that's merged what will happen is
cloud build will kick in again
should kick in this time and it will
create a rollout to staging and then
once that's there we basically at this
point we've increased our speed because
we are getting we're getting more
signals on our pull requests about what
the state is and because we're deploying
straight to staging so that means it's
basically at this point just a business
decision about whether you want to go
all the way to something like continuous
deployment where instead of a manual
approval check in the middle you could
be maybe running some automation against
staging and then deploying right to
production the other thing that we can
do is we can actually push things even
further left
you might have noticed that I've been
doing my editing in Cloud workstations
so Cloud workstations comes with
minicube
and since we're using Cloud deploy
Cloud deploy uses scaffold and scaffold
lets you do local development Loops
really easily so what I can do
is I can start running scaffold Dev and
what this does is it uses the same
scaffold configuration file that cloud
deploy is using to deploy deploy to
production it's building my image and
then it's running it locally inside
Cloud workstations using minicube
I just can't believe that those tests
didn't run
um
while we're waiting for that
see if there's anything oh it well at
least it did the did the deployment but
not the tests well that is just a
mystery what happened there so anyways
the merge that I did has triggered the
cloud build yaml that has a deployment
which is doing a build and push and then
it's generating an s-bomb and then it's
going to create once that's completed
it'll create a new rule out to staging
over here
all right so meanwhile back here we're
waiting for our local deployment to
stabilize so one other cool thing about
Cloud workstations is it does automatic
port forwarding for you so the URL that
I'm going to here you might not be able
to see because it's very small it has
Port 80 in it so I'm hitting Port 80 on
my workstation in order to do this but
my using mini Cube and scaffold my
application is running on Port 8080. so
all I have to do is change the url to
8080 and I can actually hit the version
of my application that's running in
Cloud workstations using minicube and
scaffold and it will do hot reloading as
well so if I start making changes to
this it'll get rebuilt automatically and
redeployed so I can actually push things
all the way left to my local development
environment and see the changes as I
make them
Okay so we've increased the stability
we've increased the speed the last thing
I want to talk to you about is
increasing the security posture of the
project
so let's take a look at some of these
things that we've deployed
to Cloud deploy so we can actually go
and look at the artifacts that we
deployed
and both
uh
both Cloud deploy and Cloud build have
this feature where oh that's not one I
want to show you though because that one
doesn't
[Music]
cancel
um
I want to show you the security insights
oh that's not a good one sorry let me go
over to Cloud build
again
and I want to show you the security
insights panel for some of these so that
one should have one
now if it doesn't I will be
sad
build artifacts security insights
all right okay so here is an artifact
that we built using Cloud build and
using the security insights panel we can
see that the artifact meets the
requirements for salsa build level two
we can see that there was one
vulnerability that was found inside the
image we can also see the Vex statements
that were generated and stored in
artifact registry
and you might remember I was showing a
step that generates an s-bomb using
artifact registry so this is the result
of that and then finally because we were
using Cloud build we generated salsa 1.0
provenance which you can see here that's
also stored in artifact registry and
this has all the information about
exactly what went into building this
artifact
so what you can do with this is using a
combination of the Vex statements and
the s-bombs you can use those to answer
questions like this new vulnerability
that came out is it affecting any of my
images that are running in production
and using provenance you can create
policies around the things that you
deploy to production for example
in my kubernetes clusters I'm using this
binosc policy and it's using a new
feature called a salsa check
which is so new that you can only use it
in audit mode right now so it produces
logs when images fail to check it
doesn't actually stop them from being
deployed at least not yet but what this
does is it requires that anything that's
deployed to production was built with
Cloud build and that it uses build as
code so that'll ensure that anything
that's making it into production is
actually using all of this automation
that we set up
so
I guess the test didn't just decide to
run at the end there so ignoring that
particular issue this is how you can
improve the speed stability and the
security posture of your applications
using Cloud build Cloud deploy artifact
registry Cloud workstations and binary
authorization
so if you're interested in doing any of
that the repository that I was using is
public and it has all of the
configuration that I was using there
and in the meantime I'd like to welcome
Mark to the stage from thoughtworks
who's going to be talking about some
examples from industry of devops that
show what this actually looks like in
real life
foreign
[Applause]
thank you Chrissy
and may I just note
it was a wonderful demo
if you don't have demo issues it means
the demo force is not with you today
having done this many times myself
so I want to thank both Nate and Christy
for
introducing Dora and the concepts of
Dora very very important subject
and also for a wonderful demo
and
I must say that
where am I okay there we are
and
so first of all let me introduce myself
I'm Mark Richter
I'm the head of practice at thoughtworks
for Google cloud in North America
benefits for about a dozen years I've
been using Google Cloud for about eight
of those years and I'm you I've been
using a Google Cloud workstation for all
of my development since last November
which leads me to say that I don't know
where you are but from where I am Google
cloud is the only Cloud you need
um and as some of you may know uh to
introduce going forward here with some
results thoughtworks
indeed pioneered
um continuous integration and continuous
delivery
about eight years ago and it was first
published by jez Humble in his seminal
book continuous delivery
in 2011.
and
what I want to what I want to go into is
taking that those Concepts Andorra and
talking to you about
what this means in terms of delivering
actual business value from doing
continuous integration and continuous
delivery because at the end of the day
why do we do this stuff we do this to
derive business value for our companies
from these techniques right so that
we're more profitable and we keep people
employed
so let me talk first about a huge global
Electronic Component manufacturing firm
this firm client of ours 100
microservices
and they brought us in
we used domain driven design
to strangulate a legacy of cots
application software into a microservice
architecture
building it and deploying it using cincd
and you can see the impressive results
here impressive results like this
mean that the Rapid Release and new
features to production is now business
as usual for this company
so and and let me emphasize that getting
to the point where you're releasing
multiple times a week potentially
multiple times a day you're committing
code to production you have
multiple times a day you have high
confidence that you're not breaking
things why because you're running tons
of automated tests against it all part
of the process
and then you're measuring
you're measuring using the four key
metrics
so this is a very very notable
automobile manufacturer
and here we help them with 50
microservices Reaching Across all
aspects of the business sales after
sales Parts marketing e-commerce and CRM
now they see less than a week
lead time to change
they can deploy tested reliable code to
production every day
the meantime to recover from failure is
under an hour
now 20 years ago working for another
company and
doing an e-commerce product
I would have given my left leg for an
mttr under an hour
so this is a really big deal
and it's not rocket science
none of it is it's all achieved through
discipline
and automation lots and lots of
automation
this Bank
asked us to help them with the
reliability of their release process
and so we introduced radically more
automated testing
and achieved continuous delivery which
again is business as usual for them now
so finally this telecommunications firm
brought us they brought us in to help
them with Comprehensive agile
modernization
and they now have the capability to do
over 250 releases a year
compared to just five releases a year in
the old days
think about that think think about the
business value in being able to reliably
push 250 releases into production a year
compared to five
with high confidence
so
that's that's my little presentation of
some really I mean these are real world
examples of things that we have done for
our clients
if you'd like to talk to us more about
this you can visit thoughtworks in Booth
1709 down in the exhibit hall
and to wrap things up I will hand off to
shomo who's going to talk about devops
on the ground
foreign
[Applause]
okay so I generally say very bold
statements and bear with me because
you're gonna judge me but don't do it
until I finish
so forget deployment frequency
uh forget velocity
forget lead time forget Automation and
I'm going to prove to you why every
statement I just said is true
devops at the score is not what I'm
going to share today it's devops that
everybody should be doing and the way
the way the way they should be doing it
so if I'm not going to focus on the
metrics of Dora right now we'll get to
how you complement Dora but Dora can
actually hide huge epic failures metrics
can hurt a lot of people the reason
being is businesses have responses to
pressures to show good metrics versus
actually correcting the problem itself
so let's start with principles
if I need devops velocity or let's call
it happiness which is really what we're
after it's not speed it's happiness and
devops is the ability to collaborate
with others that are part of a whole for
delivery you need see alignment so we
have three principles in each principle
actually results in devops functioning
at Elite practice
so the chro is concerned with people
leaving companies people feeling
unhealthy people having mental health
issues which is a real thing for
Frontline people people who do
deployments and worry about the company
how it's going to resolve issues
the value has to be delivered in a way
that is separate from you enjoying your
life
simple principle but we'll support
orchestration not automation automation
is
maintained by people who are smes
orchestration links automation together
which releases that person from having
to be there
ceio principle you may not change
existing services or machines this
promotes CI CD this promotes deployment
strategies this promotes immutable
environments this just promotes not
keeping changes that we consider to be
oh I wasn't expecting that to happen the
reason it happened is you have drift you
have a lot of environments that you
don't know what they are you don't know
the state of them so don't change them
make new ones
the third one is nobody has access to
Shared environments again this is beyond
zero trust it's absent trust remove
access you don't require entirely and
have CISD and get flow get up to
actually build and deploy so you don't
need to go into environments so this
helps advance observability
to full stack observability having
Telemetry and metrics that you require
again devops principles for happiness
all of these try to make sure that you
are not the hero that takes a toll when
bad happens you are not the hero
when something needs to be deployed you
are not the hero that has to make demos
work which you can't
not specific here it's every demo every
demo
so I'm going to actually go into the
math and I'll there's some stuff that's
not shared here so how does
organizations actually fix and present
these metrics
you can add people
there's a downside to adding people
a large downside because you distribute
the work across a lot of people you lose
your smeeze we're not looking at that in
Dora metrics
you could remove steps that's every
digital team at every company they just
say well I have no regulations I can
just do it without all these steps and
go straight to production wickedly fast
really shitty quality really bad
confidence right because you're just
skipping things you're missing things
the last one is essentially resilience
and orchestration right you're going to
improve efficiency which is really what
you should be targeting not automation
because automation again is maintained
by smes it ruins your life you have to
be around who here hasn't had to work on
ansible errors exit codes
right you have to manage it put it into
orchestration so your your your tests
always operate in a consistent fashion
because they're run in a consistent
fashion so why is time to Market and
release frequency irrelevant they're
just pressures I could make it up
I could do weekly I could do daily
what's good ruining lives
probably not so how are you getting your
metrics so essentially what you should
be targeting is efficiency
based on the human effort required to
release forget run time again if I have
lead time and I want to release but I
have to do old appropriate testing to
prevent outages let it run who's it
affecting nobody the software goes out
when it needs to with the appropriate
controls testing that's orchestrated
so again lead time time to Market
release frequency oh you don't
need those metrics you need to know how
is it hurting people how are the teams
working together Which business process
isn't included and make sure the
orchestration does that for you
so this is the how so that's how you
measure it Dora does measure pain but
you can hide Pain by hiring people you
can hide Pain by skipping steps and then
you get your deployment frequency it
looks great on paper but ruins lives
but what does what does good look like
if I'm doing the mathematics because you
you can actually make it into equation
for everything
Innovation potential is basically a
function of spare time so let's say you
assign a certain amount of Engineers
every engineer has something like 20 of
their time related to the application
which is reasonable they get familiar
with the app their smee's but you also
need spare time to innovate what's too
much
so like you have to balance this it's
it's kind of like an equilibrium you
need to find a place where someone's
engaged enough but still has spare time
to innovate and it's complicated that's
what door should be focusing on
so that you reduce heroics but you also
don't destroy your smee's it's it's
again a balance
again resilience is a function of the
efficiency of the whole process be it QA
testing be it Dev testing deployments
all of that stuff how efficient is these
are those processes I guarantee in this
entire room QA is most likely the most
inefficient and that's why we can't get
out very quickly again because there
hasn't been much investment on QA
automation as of yet
uh which gets orchestrated I don't want
to step in that one
um again sustainability is a function of
idle time how many people here and I'll
ask question how many people here run a
non-prod environment that runs all the
time you never destroy it or turn it off
so we're killing the planet
right so the context I always go with an
analogy you if you if you lease a car or
you rent a car if you're not using it
what did you return the rental
you're paying for it in this case the
environment pays for water heating
cooling all of that but we leave
environments sitting if you go back to
the principles where you you
don't change an existing machine then
why would I leave a machine running I
have the ability to create it and
destroy it it's all linked together and
its intent is to prevent idle time again
those idle systems become hard for us to
manage again ruining lives but again if
we go back to Dora and we take metrics
that go I release daily frequently
hourly whatever it is what does it mean
to the people behind it do we actually
measure the impact to the individuals
that bear this burden as we increase the
frequency do we have the resilience to
manage the business pressure
so epic failures can occur with
fantastic Dora metrics unless we measure
the impact on the human
which is each of us
I'll stop there
I don't want to take too much any I can
keep going
so
I'll go back here and try to go into the
capabilities that you achieve uh
for one most organizations without these
principles you don't have alignment from
leaders so devops only occurs when all
the business processes people technology
and experience I don't know why we still
use people process like techno
technology experiences where the
happiness occurs experience is what
you're actually after the to make sure
the experience across the entire it
organization occurs
you you have the metrics you require to
be informed of your environment and your
applications
you do not persist environments just
because it's convenient to leave it it's
actually not convenient to leave it it
has huge tolls on people maybe not
yourself but on other other members of
the organization and then generally or
organizations think buying tools fix
things because they bought Automation
and they're like it's 40 automated but
the reality is you should be focusing on
what what are people doing when are they
spending their time slack productivity
says how many messages do you send I
want to know how many messages are at
night I want to know how many messages
are on weekends do they present that
data no they just whoever can get the
highest number of uh messages is the
best
so the context here is if you go by
principle versus metrics the metrics
will result from maintaining your
principles which is what we should all
be doing this is the piece that's
missing it's not about showing metrics
that look good it's about making sure
the people who work with you are happy
and enjoying their work and hopefully
you drive down attrition and you don't
lose or ruin anybody's lives maintain
devops happiness not velocity
thanks
[Applause]
all right thank you everyone
one more thing
I can't really talk about it but please
keep looking out this week there may be
something more that happens
yeah
with that uh here's some other sessions
to check out they're all good they're
great one of them might even have me in
it again and
um yeah that's it go to lunch